hi everyone and thanks to the organizers
for inviting me to give this talk
my name is bob west and i'm an assistant
professor of computer science at epfl in
switzerland
what i'm about to present is work in
progress that we're doing in the context
of the microsoft touring academic
program
most of the credit here goes to my
postdoc maxine pera who is leading this
project and also to my phd student
martin joseforski as well as to our
fantastic team of collaborators for
microsoft research and touring
the starting point for this work is the
observation that machine learning
algorithms tend to pick up on spurious
correlations
that is correlations that don't reflect
causal relationships in the world
let me use an example that has been
popular in the previous literature and
that nicely relates to where i live
switzerland
imagine that you want to train a machine
learning algorithm to detect cows and
images
a large fraction of cow images on the
internet were taken in all pine settings
so in many cow images we'll have a grass
and we have grass on the ground
snow-covered mountains in the back etc
this can lead the machine learning
algorithms to rely on such features in
order to decide whether there is a cow
in the image
but cows of course exist in many other
settings as well
for example in the mediterranean
environment of corsica
there's no swiss style setting here with
grass and mountains so algorithms
trained on typical data sets of cows
won't find the features
that that the algorithm has learned to
rely on and it will fail to recognize
many cow images as such
so in a nutshell the problem is that
causation doesn't equal correlation
while i use the task of image
classification to motivate the problem
our project actually focuses on the task
of language modeling here the input
is word sequences rather than pixel maps
but the same problems arise
how can we fix these problems
recent work has focused on two broad
approaches bias mitigation on the one
hand and causal inference and reasoning
on the other hand
the bias mitigation based approach is
bottom-up here one starts by observing a
specific cure spurious correlation such
as gender bias for example
and then adds a penalty to the loss
function in order to steer the model
away from paying attention to those
spurious correlations
the causal inference based approach on
the other hand is top down here one
starts
from a causal graph of the model
situation and then one identifies
spurious correlations as those
correlations that don't correspond to
the causal
paths in the graph
both of these approaches have certain
shortcomings
bias mitigation can be a tedious
never-ending process that doesn't scale
up easily
usually whenever you remove one type of
sphere's correlation others pop in it's
like a hydra you chop off one of its
heads
and it grows two more
moreover some forms of spheres
correlation can be inherently hard to
detect and measure we might not even
know there is a sphere's correlation in
the first place
causal inference based approaches
on the other side also have major
problems for example writing down a
causal graph is notoriously hard
sometimes it's not even clear at all how
to begin to think of a causal model for
a given domain in the first place
and language modeling our task
is precisely of this nature
typical language is constrained by
causal relationships in the world for
example when i tell my daughter to not
press the escape key
while i work because it will make me
lose all my unsafe work she only
understands this because somewhere in
her head she has a causal model that
specifies that a key press has
consequences inside a computer that the
computer also stores the work i do and
so on
current language models don't encompass
such causal models but are exclusively
based on work co-occurrences and are
thus vulnerable to spheres correlations
a rigorous
a rigorous causal inference based
approach to removing
spurious correlations would require us
to first model all those causal
relationships in the world an impossibly
difficult task
it is not even clear what should be the
variables in such a causal model in the
first place let alone the causal links
order to build up our approach toward
removing spurious correlations from
language models let me retrace some of
the recent advances in causal machine
learning
one key observation called invariance
across environments and first rigorously
made by peters at all in 2015 is that
causal that is non-spurious correlations
are stable across environments
let's revisit the cow example here
background features do not generalize
across environments
switzerland versus corsica et cetera
because the typical background is
different in switzerland than in corsica
features
of the cows
themselves
however such as the shape of the horns
noses ears etc are the same regardless
of where the cow is situated
so those features
generalize across environments
in order to enforce
um
invariants across environments aryovsky
at all have proposed invariant risk
minimization irm a generalization of the
standard expected risk minimization
framework which i will refer to as erm
and here erm expected risk minimization
is really just a fancy word for the
standard loss that typical machine
learning training algorithms
such as neural networks strive to
minimize
but whereas in erm
expected risk minimization there is no
notion of environments
irm invariant risk minimization assumes
that the data is partitioned into
several disjoint environments in the
example on this slide there are two
environments a and b
and the task is to train a
classification model
for example to distinguish cow images
from no
from no cow images
in the irm framework one classification
model is associated with each
environment but the models are not
independent rather each model is
decomposed into two stages a feature
extractor phi
that operates on the raw data
and a classifier wawb etc that operates
on the extracted features
the same feature extractor phi
is shared by all environments
and the models are tied together by an
objective function that stipulates
that
the optimal classifier
one per environment should be identical
across all the environments
so in a nutshell the goal is to find a
feature extractor phi
such that all the optimal environment
specific classifiers
become identical
it turns out that this is quite a hard
optimization problem though
so follow-up work has investigated how
to perform the optimization efficiently
in particular irm games is an algorithm
that results from considering the
optimization problem as a game between
the environments and the task now
becomes fine becomes finding a nash
equilibrium for this game
which can be shown to recover the
optimal phi
and w
to approximate the nash equilibrium of
this game each environment performs
gradient descent steps on its own
environment environment specific
classifier and all the environments also
update the shared feature extracted file
after each batch of training the
environment specific classifiers are
then averaged in order to obtain the
global classifier w
zooming out i'd like to point out that
the notion of invariance across
environments strikes a nice balance
between the most common paradigms for
spheres correlation removal bias
mitigation and causal inference on the
one hand
unlike
causal inference approaches based on
invariants across environment do not
require specifying a causal model
on the other hand unlike bias mitigation
we need not specify each and every bias
rather the focus shifts to choosing a
partitioning of the data into disjoint
environments
let me put together the concepts we've
covered so far
in variance across environment in
variance across environments iae is a
high-level notion a way of
characterizing causality via invariance
irm
is one level down in the implementation
stack it provides an objective function
that operationalizes in variance across
environments
rm games finally is even further down in
the on the implementation stack it
provides an efficient way of performing
the optimization specified by irm
let's look at iron games in action on a
language modeling task
in the forward pass
we
we encode text using phi
the feature extractor
we pass it through each classifier
and then
build
the average
to obtain the global classifier
on the backward pass if the data point
is from environment a
then we update
the model via then we update via back
propagation
wa the environment specific classifier
part and phi the global feature
extractor
if however the data point is from
environment b
then we update only
wb the classifier specific to
environment b
and also again the global feature
extractor phi
so you see that the feature extractor
phi is always updated regardless from
which environment a data point is coming
whereas the classifier
wa wb etc is updated only for the
respective environment
this was the theory so let's see if it
works in practice
a disclaimer this is work in progress so
what i'll show you is just a glimpse at
some early results
our goal is to see if training a
language model with irm rather than with
the standard erm results in fewer
spurious correlations
in order to have a clean setup where we
can study this question we carefully
craft a set of environments with minimal
and controlled changes such that we can
actually tell
um whether spears correlation was
removed or not
as a concrete example
we will use gender bias it is well known
that in naturally occurring text many
words such as profession names doctor
nurse bricklayer etc
are statistically associated with
certain genders
so there's a correlation between those
words the profession names in the
example i gave and with gender words
for example pronouns such as he she etc
in order to make sure that these are
spurious correlations we also synthesize
an artificial environment where all
gender terms
are inverted for example he becomes she
she becomes he etc specifically we split
the original data into two environments
with proportion p versus one minus p
the fraction p of the original corpus is
completely left unchanged
changed nothing down there the remaining
portion
1 minus p
is
modified such that we simply invert all
gender terms for example whenever we see
he we change it to she whenever we see
she we change it to he and so on
so we refer to these two environments a
a is the unchanged one b is the changed
one
as a result the environments a and b
come from essentially the same
distribution
the only difference being
the correlations of words with gender
words
in our evaluation we will then consider
two setups a balanced and an unbalanced
set up
the intuition here
is that in the balanced setup both irm
and erm should successfully remove
gender correlation
why is that well because since we've in
environment b the um
the gender terms are flipped basically
any correlation any spurious correlation
bias that we have originally in
environment b is cancelled out by
flipping
the bias in environment b that's in the
balanced setup in the unbalanced setup
however
we have um
four times as much uh from the original
corpus as in from the flipped
portion so that means there is still a
preponderance of the original bias and
it's only slightly turned around to a
certain extent in the flipped portion
the flip portion is overwritten so here
we would expect erm to fail because
the bias is effectively still there
whereas irm should in the ideal case
that we would hope work
because it can separate those two
environments from each other a and b
to train the language model we start
from a pre-trained model that one was
pre-trained via standard neural network
training that is via erm and then we
fine-tune it via irm
if the model successfully removes
um so um and if a model successfully
removes the spurious correlation with
gender terms
then whenever at test time the model is
asked to predict a mass word whose
ground truth is a gendered pronoun
then it the model should give an equal
probability to the male and to the
female version of that pronoun
technically the entropy over the gender
variance should be large
so let's look at the results first we
consider the balance scenario here the
dashed line is the entropy of the the
gender variance before irm-based
fine-tuning
so we see that in the balanced setting
both erm and irm have an entropy higher
than the dash pre-fine-tuned tuning
baseline so by fine-tuning both erm and
irm
remove some bias but irm in blue does so
even more
next the unbalanced setup as you can see
the effect is much stronger in the
unbalanced setting
on the right
here irm's entropy increases by an even
larger margin over the pre
pre-fine-tuning baseline as compared to
erm the gap between blue and red is
larger on the right than on the left
so to summarize irm provides an
effective way of making language models
more robust to biases and thus
generalized better
so let me conclude
typical language is constrained by
causal relationships in the world
to model language properly one might
think we would first have to model all
those causal relationships in the world
that would be really hard
what are even the variables that such a
causal model would have to include it's
unclear
irm invariant risk minimization offers
some of the robustness that we could
hope to achieve via proper causal
modeling without having to specify the
causal model explicitly
therefore we consider irm a well-suited
paradigm for language model
here i showed you a first glimpse
i'm looking forward to continuing our
investigations together with the
microsoft touring team and to share more
results with you in the future
so thanks for your attention
if you have any questions or comments i
would be happy to receive them via email
thanks a lot